[Música]
cinco años de fama y 26 cortos años de
vida marilia mendonça la mega estrella
brasileña de la música country ha muerto
en un accidente aéreo se dirigía a dar
un concierto en caratinga en el estado
suroriental de minas gerais el productor
de la ganadora del grammy latino o su
tío y los dos pilotos también murieron
la policía ya abrió una investigación
los restos de una antena sugieren que el
avión colisionó con ella antes de caer
de socios
[Música]
con su canción infiel sobre el engaño
mendoza saltó a la fama nacional en 2016
relaciones fallidas y empoderamiento
femenino el tema resultó ser una fórmula
ganadora y lanzó un éxito tras otro
acumulando miles de millones de visitas
en youtube y convirtiéndose a la artista
más escuchada de spotify en brasil en
2019 y 2020 su amigo íntimo el
futbolista neymar tuiteó que se negaba a
creer lo ocurrido el presidente yair
bolsonaro declaró por su parte que todo
el país estaba conmocionado por el
fallecimiento de una de las mayores
artistas de su generación
además de su legado de ofrecer una
perspectiva femenina en un género
musical tradicionalmente machista
conocido como el ser tan hijo marilia
mendonça deja atrás a su hijo que
cumplirá dos años el próximo mes
[Música]